it's absolutely true that skooled makes
people show up sit down shut up and that
these are useful skills for people to
live in adulthood so the real question
is if all we're trying to do is prepare
people or job line to prepare them with
a job I'm Nick Gillespie for reason and
today we are talking with the author of
what is almost certainly going to be the
most controversial book of the year
Bryan Caplan is an economics professor
at George Mason University and his new
book is the case against education Bryan
thanks for talking with reason thanks
for such an exciting introduction well
let's get right to it early on you say
flatly you write flatly this book argues
that our education system is a big waste
of time and money and now you're not
simply saying that our schools are
overpriced and uneven in quality you are
actually making the case that much of
our traditional education system
especially higher ed is literally a
waste of time right what do you mean by
that what I mean is that people are
going there to get a higher income but
they're actually not getting much of the
way of job skills which raises a big
puzzle for an economist how can they be
getting a higher income if they're not
getting much in the way of job skills
and my answer comes down to something
called the signaling model education
that says that a lot of the reason why
education pays isn't that you learn
useful skills but that you distinguish
yourself that you're getting stamped or
labeled you're getting a sticker on your
forehead grade a worker okay it's kind
of like you come out as a piece of steak
your USDA exact line but you haven't
been cooked yet precisely and the key
thing about this is you know selfishly
speaking doesn't really matter why
you're getting more money but from a
social point of view from the point of
view of is this a good use of taxpayer
dollars it matters tremendously because
if everybody just gets more years in
education and all you're doing is
showing off then you're just raising the
bar for how much school you need in
order to get a job in the first place so
let's talk about the magnitude of wasted
time and money
you know I guess for for most people if
you go from kindergarten through a BA
you're talking about 17 years probably
so that's a lot of time but how much
money do we spend as a society on
education yeah so government funding is
about two trillion dollars a year when
you add up all levels our economy is
about 20 trillion oh yeah that's
something like a five five percent of
all GDP and then
of course private spending tops it up a
bit for a bit further sir you know
there's something about something over a
trillion and by the way that one thing
that's interesting about this is you
don't really make a distinction between
private and public education because
that's that this isn't a book about like
how you know the public school system is
failing it's it's just how education is
useless I mean I know libertarians wanna
hear different story but I'm telling the
story that I think is true rather the
story that's you know that I would even
would even find ideologically in most
most congenial I mean they the main
thing that is the you know I've got I've
gone to public school on a private
school I don't really see very much
difference and in both cases it seems to
me that most of what's going on is
showing off in order to look better for
the labor market which again
individually makes perfect sense but
socially speaking everyone can't be
above average so this is kind of like
you know a private private vise is
actually becomes a public vise because
but or rather a private virtue becomes a
public vise yeah cause yeah I mean I
mean I think of this as a you know as
educational as being a lot like football
stadiums where you know like the me the
main libertarian complain about football
stadiums isn't that we're not making the
right kind of football stadium since
that government is pouring a ton of
money on something and like ends really
the what we need is to have fewer and
worse football stadiums right yes four
people have spent in a meaningful way
yeah yeah awesomely not on football
stadiums totally different things before
we go into the signaling model per se
talk a little bit about the human
capital model of Education yes because
these are the two big creating
explanations what is the human capital
education model yeah the human capital
model is a fancy phrase for what your
teachers and politicians and your
parents have been telling you which is
you go to school to get smart and to
learn all kinds of useful stuff which
are then going to apply in the real
world you're investing in yourself
you're investing yourself so you're
transforming unskilled labor into a
skilled talented adults most associated
with Gary Becker yo-yoing a famous Nobel
Prize winning economist but really he
was just putting an academic veneer on
something that is widely propagandize in
favor of the idea of school as a skills
Factory it's not simply I mean very few
people and I mean you point this out
continuously in the book and I and I
think accurately
nobody you know if you go to take a shop
class you're not gonna go and learn how
to cut ninja stars out of you know the
sheets of metal and that's the job
you're gonna have in a factory but the
idea is that you learn skills that you
learn how to show up on time you learn
how to listen and follow instructions
you've learned how to self learn and
you're saying that this is actually not
a very like how do you know that that's
not inaccurate right that's one of the
best arguments in favor of the education
we have it's won by the way the people
usually have to be forced into and after
a series of intellectual retreats but
here's the main thing that I say about
that it's absolutely true that skooled
makes people show up sit down shut up
and that these are useful skills for
people to learn to have an adulthood so
the real question is if all we're trying
to do is prepare people or job line to
prepare them with a job instead of with
school where the overlap there is like
partial overlap in skills but there's
course there's a lot of stuff that
you're taught in school that is
dysfunctional in the real world like
every it's very important for everything
to be fair if jobs aren't fair but
school everything has to be fair talk
about the sheepskin effect because for
me this is the thing that totally
whatever affection I had for the human
capital model of Education this really
kind of kicked that to the curb so
diplomas used to be written on the skins
of sheep and the sheep skin effect
refers to the fact that a lot of the
payoff from education comes from
crossing the finish line from graduation
a disproportionate amount so like in the
book I just average over a whole lot of
studies Swiss for college
see if finishing senior year pays
something like seven times as much as a
regular year
seven times as much now either we save
almost all the useful job skills for
graduation here which sounds really
implausible immunity of senior year's
goof-off year not finally learn some job
skills here or there's something
something going on in the rewards for
education that's not about skills that
you're learning and I say no like like
the main thing that we're getting is
it's a signal of conformity in our
society you are expected to graduate
everyone tells you to graduate if you
failed to do so despite all of this
social pressure you're saying something
very bad about yourself and the labour
market responds negatively to you
although one of the things that is I
think really interesting about the book
is that you do steer clear of extremes
because there are
immediately you can hear people saying
well what about Steve Jobs what about
Bill Gates you know what about Michael
Dell there's a you know the list of or
Andrew Carnegie for that matter you know
I so I mean you're not saying that all
of these things are you know infinite
extremely perfectly right yeah of course
so you know I have two chapters in the
book that are the most quantitative part
rice that around trying to crunch the
numbers and say what fraction of the
payoff for education comes from human
capital what fraction comes from
signaling of course you learned reading
and writing in math in school to some
degree and of course those are useful
job skills but what fraction of the time
that you're in school is really learning
is you're really learning anything
you're ever gonna use again what
fraction of the payoff comes from what
you've learned rather than what you've
demonstrated you can do what do you do
with the arguments that well school
maybe or education and particularly K
through 12 education is not for job
skills but it's for citizenship and this
is not you know it the Progressive Era
talked a lot about then like we need to
make good citizens especially out of
increased numbers of immigrants who had
no understanding of American history
where does that fall in the human
capital model right so I mean that would
actually be totally outside of it giving
like human capital versus signalling or
trying to figure out why do employers
pay you more for it now this other stuff
I have a full chapter on it as well and
it begins with saying look the argument
in principle is sound but we have to
look empirically to see whether it's
really true you know I have a big
section where I just go over how much
civics do American adults even know and
the answer is next to nothing next to
nothing yes you've note that if people
who were born here or citizens had to
pass the citizenship test of immigrants
but I think was something like 70% fail
I'm glad you remember that I don't but
yes I mean what we can see is that like
even the most basic stuff like how many
senators each state have maybe half of
American adults know this this is not
after I got a 1 week course in civics so
you know like the only like so American
high school students on average would do
three years of civics and history so
three years and yet what do we have to
show for it and so next nothing well we
have a football state yes we have
football stadiums so talk about the
signaling model how does the signaling
model work you say
you know hardly it shows that you're
willing to conform to certain basic
norms that are gonna make you appealing
to employers but but there's more dates
than that yes so I mean there's a lot of
different desirable traits that you were
signalling with educational
accomplishments so there's the obvious
ones you're signalling they're smart
smart people do better in school if
you've done well in school
natural influence is the person's
probably smart not necessarily by
generally you're signalling work ethic
because even the smarter person in the
world can't do well in school if they
don't if they don't show up and do a bit
of work and then finally the the the
most subtle one that I talked about a
lot is conformity signaling you're
willing to submit to social norms and
again that's conformity one is where we
really get things like the sheepskin
effect you think over adjust signaling
intelligence of work ethic there still
isn't really a good story well why does
the last year pay so much once you
accept that a lot of it is about new yes
master I will conform to what our
society demands of me that's where
graduation so important that's why in a
country or college last three years it's
the third year that's crucial run
country over the last four years or the
fourth year that's crucial you know just
like in a country where suits for the
standard thing you were it really better
wear a suit or else you look like a
weirdo and people don't want to hire you
libertarianism is about individualism
but then you know what is there a
sliding scale of like when you get too
conformist because then you're also not
a good worker right in many ways it's
like you're like Atomics professor if
you were simply doing what everybody
else was doing that would be a problem
allowing that I that I quote in the book
roughly is what employers want is
intelligent conformism they want people
who apply their full intellectual power
to the task that is given to them now
sometimes there are creative occupations
where they're told being creative on
this task right we even there you know
almost no employer wants you to be so
creative that you say and maybe this
project isn't worth doing maybe I should
be the boss so there's always that and
then again of course most jobs are not
really very creative and there's a
tendency in the information age to focus
on the small share of jobs where we do
want people shooting by shooting
basketball were they where they shoot
the breeze but even most jobs are not
like that vast majority of jobs are not
like that it's about there's a customer
he wants a definite product given that
product or else I don't want you around
talk about one of the ways that this
system gets enforced is through you talk
about social desirability by yeah
you know what what is that and how does
that inform the larger education right
so you know social desirability bias is
the concept in psychology that is barely
known by either economist or
libertarians and yet should be the
single most of the most cited concept in
psychology social desirability bias you
know a civil version is people like to
say what sounds good
they like to say things they'll make
people think that they are a kind and a
kind respectful and respectable person
alright so you can see this in the thing
of things like you know what is the
socially desirable answer - am i fat of
course well of course the end socially
desirable answer is I'm not fat now of
course some people aren't fat and then
use telling the truth but on the other
hand we know that if someone is in fact
fat our strong temptation is to say
something that sounds good but isn't
true this is something where of course
we see it in daily life but also has
clear political role so you know just
think about any time a politician says
and we need to put more resources into
education health care and the
environment all right now these are all
things that sound good and if you can
imagine a politician saying we have now
done enough for education and health
care in the environment we are there
they're important but enough is enough
that's nothing that a politician would
ever want to stick their neck out and
say because it sounds bad it sounds like
you're not a caring person you're not a
respectable person when I say something
a lot of the support for education is
social desirability bias ya sense that
if we have that like only the only thing
that a good person would say is more and
better never less and worse there are
obviously entrenched interests in the
kind of education industry as well as it
helps employers right because employers
even if we're not learning the skills
you know they're they're gonna train us
on the job for whatever we need to do
but they benefit in a way right from you
know the signaling process because it
makes it you at one point you say that
you know employers can't look at every
individual an applicant closely so they
use these as ruff sorts yeah I mean
employers benefit from there being some
signal but I'd only employers benefit
from the college degree being the signal
of quality rather than high school
degree so something where you know like
you like in nineteen fifty it wouldn't
wait like about though you know some of
this may at twenty five percent of
American adults would have finished high
school at that point and then a lawyer
can say well a high school graduate
great perfect though manager
real material now it's a college degree
as to why employers benefit from polling
four years worth of labour off the off
the job market I don't think they do
actually well so yeah can we talk about
that what is the you know what is the
historical the kind of material basis
for this you know again schools became
you know at least up through sixth grade
or eighth grade for most kids sort of
become mandatory in the early 19th
century by the end of the century was
everywhere as part of this as part of
the the growth of education as being so
important than central to our identity
is it simply we need to warehouse kids
now that we don't need them to be
chimney sweeps or to you know do you
know like things you know kids have
little hands they can work on machines
with little hands things like that or
hock newspapers we don't need them to do
that labor anymore we just warehousing
kids like what's the sociology of Y or
the genealogy of why we have so much
education going back hundred years there
is this popular story that employers
wanted kids trained to be cogs and the
in the corporate machine I would say let
you know if you really wanted to train
cogs in your corporate machine you would
not design anything like the public
school system we have it would be like
military school you would whip kids into
shape get them to say yes sir give them
a lot of propaganda about how great
their corporate paymasters are that's
not the way that education looked a
hundred years ago and it's certainly not
the way that looks today this is not a
system that really seems to be designed
to prepare employers employ and prepare
people to be to be useful useful boys
you never have the everyone's a
beautiful unique snowflake kind of
propaganda the touchy-feely Nestle no
that's not the what bit of employers
want employers want someone that will
follow orders do what they're told and
lie and accept criticism which is of
course crucial for learning so I don't
think that you know that it really makes
much sense to think of the current
system is something that has been molded
for the interests of corporate America I
mean I think you know so corporate
America of course they they want they
can tweak it a little bit more and their
favorite record is what else would we do
with kids
yeah so well so there's kids and kids
yeah right young kids of course you know
they need to be warehoused right so you
know so give them daycare or leave it
there as to why kids can't go to a go to
school and then learn reading writing in
math for a few hours and they get to
play for the rest of the day within a
supervised facility we've got no clue
about why
couldn't just do that rather than boring
them to death with making them study
stuff they don't care about but even for
older kids you know like you know for
like thirteen year olds fourteen or
fifteen year olds as to why they can't
actually be out of the real world as
apprentices there are countries to do
this Germany and Switzerland do this
no reason why American kids could not do
this as well right and yes they like
their they can't do anything sure they
can do stuff say well we don't need them
well I mean like the economy's not based
upon what we need it's based upon what
we got right now there's a like I said
what do we need we need like a few balls
or ice a day but what we what we've got
however is enough to go and produce
vastly more like I don't see any reason
why why why teenagers could not be part
of the labor market a much earlier age
and they are right now right and of
course if we're always worried that any
kid who's working is being distracted
from his all from as much more important
studies this is gonna fly but if we
realize you know these studies are not
really that's socially valuable anyway
and like we better to get kids in the
labor force especially by the way kids
that are not very academically inclined
anyway where they get shoved and prodded
to go and succeed and go to college
which is almost certainly never going to
happen for them and by the time that
they drop out they're so bitter about
the whole system that they are not
suited for really any job got a chapter
in the book called one is greater than
zero it's like be better just to train
people to do one job rather than zero
which is what a lot of kids leave high
school or drop out of high school able
to do so what is to be done and you
right in the concluding chapter of the
book slash government subsidies this
won't make classes relevant but will
lead students to spend fewer years
sitting in classrooms since they're
learnt not learning much of use the
overarching effect will not be D
skilling but credential deflation talk
about that
yes so credential inflation is what
we've seen over the last century the
amount of education that you need to get
one in the same job has increased
dramatically so basically since World
War two would be all about a four year
increase in the amount of education need
to get a job this is why we see college
graduates doing things like waiting
tables value bartending where we're
driving taxis these are not just ultra
rare examples that make it onto the news
these are common jobs for college
graduates to have these days and it does
seem like you know even in these jobs a
college degree does pay it
you get promoted and get a position in
the bet in the better restaurants or the
better bars but even like the reason is
there's so many people with these
degrees that employers can afford to be
picky and say won't find I want to call
I want college graduates tending my
fancy bar you know like this is I say
this is a function of the amount of the
proliferation of credentials and if
education were more expensive and if
subsidies were lower fewer people would
go and we're talking subsidies here I
mean this is you know ninety percent
plus of K through 12 spending is spent
on public schools you know there's so
much federal money and then state money
going into colleges as well the private
colleges you're saying cut that
absolutely so KL cut government spending
cut the subsidies you know I say you
know this is one of the most egregious
cases of industrial policy that we see
all over the world and it's one that's
almost totally uncontroversial even
though if you go into a classroom and
say well we why are we going and and
teaching these kids that stuff they're
gonna forget it anyway and it's not
really relevant to what they're gonna do
in real life
and so why to save you from you know a
charge of Philistine ISM you're also
you're not saying in the book well you
know don't read novels no don't study
art done study music you're simply
saying that you know as part of a
curriculum most of what we learn other
than basic mathematics and literacy
including English skills is kind of
useless yes you know so you use us in
labor market now so you know I'm a
professor and I am a high culture kind
of person and German are at Shakespeare
this is the stuff that I like but I
still recognize that any other there's
something twisted about ramming it down
a kid's throat a key part of
appreciating this kind of stuff is
coming to it and your own good time
well actually actually being curious and
ready so even like you know if you know
if you could go and actually inspire
sincere affection for Shakespeare opera
that's great I see this happening almost
never in school the kids are there they
know they go and pay lip service to it
and then as soon as they're done they
walk away so well I never want to have
to hear that garbage again I hated that
stuff you know this is where I say that
while I'm not very optimistic about the
potential of online education to really
compete to do with brick-and-mortar
schools it's already doing a tremendous
job in terms of quenching the human
thirst for enlightenment
right and of course what's great about
the Internet is
you don't have to have to concentrate
all your firepower on kids that are
between 15 and 22
you can wait around for adults say I'm
30 now I'm curious about Shakespeare
seem really boring when I was young but
now maybe I would like to go and learn
something about it so we wanted to say
that while I'm all on board with the
noble goals of enlightening the human
spirits a key part of this is you've got
to have volunteers that want to learn
trust trying to ram this down the throat
of conscripts which is what education
really does you know is it is an insult
to everything that a layman stays you
know what I'm hearing Pink Floyd's the
wall playing yes yes this is the
soundtrack book
Brian Kaplan's latest book the case
against education he's a George Mason
economics professor oh so you wrote a
few years ago the myth of the rational
voter I think this book is going to be
just as controversial and hopefully as
widely read Brian thanks for talking to
me thanks so much always great talking
neck for a reason I'm Nick Gillespie
[Music]